مشهد ما عدا يمكن للعمانيين رؤيته بسهوله
في سواحل السلطنه
حمل عبد الله وصحبه على عاتقهم اعاده
تمثيله في مسعا منهم لتذكير الاجيال بحرف
اجدادهم
يعني واحد ما يعرف ماضينا يعرف ماضيهم
يعني كان يشوف ابائي عملوا كذا كانوا
اجداد يعملوا كذا حتى يمكن هو انه يتبعه
ويعمل العمله هذه على مقربه منه لم يخفي
عبد الله المقبالي قلقه امام زواره من عدم
اهتمام جيل اليوم بمهن الاجداد يعرض لهم
مقتنيات قديمه للغوص ويمتع انظارهم بجواهر
نفيسه من اللؤلؤ الطبيعي املا في تحفيزهم
اهم شيء مهنه الغوص احيانا اغلبيه المارين
واغلبيه الناس ما عنده فكره عن الغوص ولا
عنده كيف كان غوسه ولا عنده كيف ادوات
للغوص المستخدمه
البحار خدادات المخاوف نفسها
فخشيته من ضياع تجربته الثريه في صناعه
السفن وقيادتها الى الهند والعراق واليمن
وباكستان لعقود طويله دفعته للوقوف الى
جانب الشباب ونقل خبرته اليهم
[موسيقى]
خلص ومهنه
هذا ما تخلص
المهنه هو علم
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف كيلو متر هو طول سواحل
سلطنه عمان موقع استراتيجي دفع معظم سكان
البلد قبل تدفق النفط الاحتراف الصيد
والشقي عباب البحر بالسفن وجعل منهم
غواصين مهره
[موسيقى]
الزمن طويل
بمياه الخلي
ج لعمان لكن هذا النشاط صار اليوم مجرد
ذكرى تحيى كموروث شعبي وحسب بعد عزوف
الشباب عنه وانتشار مزارع اللؤلؤ الصناعيه
سمير النمر الجزيره من محافظه شمال باطنه
سلطنه عمان